okay thank you very much in particular I
wanted to thank the organizer the
organizer Zuma's thomas Ignacio and Andy
and I'm going to repeat the first half
of the ends talk now
although he saw my transparencies before
so but the second part will be a little
different so I'm gonna be talking about
quantum simulators again this analog
quantum simulators where do we stand and
first of all I wanted to mention there
are very many nice reviews about this
subject this is from 2012 but it's still
very actual a special issue of nature
physics inside actually I think a detail
by Peter solar and Ignacio serac and
this is the European quantum
technologies roadmap which is accepted
in new journal of physics should appear
soon online because this is only online
magazine edited by max reader and
Tommaso calico and here you have a
chapter on quantum simulation written by
Iain Simon will block me and Stefan code
so the outline is I will start with some
kind of ideologies very trivial but
still since this is not a physics
conference I found it appropriate to say
a little about it
I will talk what are the quantum
simulators and onion analyst are we
talking about analyst versus digital and
what do we want to simulate I will then
go to give you some examples of physics
of some simulations of interesting
physical phenomena only to probably
because there is no time and then I will
the second part will be about that as
validation and certification so in a
sense analog to what the ends was
presenting but I hope it will be less
controversial I will not talk about this
but I will be here till Friday so if
anybody wants to discuss this subject
actually I understand it will be
discussing this workshop anyway
so the ideology so I will repeat now one
of the standard lies but one of the most
famous California and physicist but kind
of modified there exist many interesting
quantum phenomena such as
superconductivity this phenomena may
have important applications these
phenomena are often difficult to be
described and understood with the help
of standard computer so maybe we can use
another simpler better controllable
quantum system to simulate understand
and control this phenomena this system
would be then a quantum computer of
special purpose named quantum simulator
here is your thousand Californian famous
physicist now the this is a lie but the
important thing that comes from this is
that the quantum simulator is the
experimental system that we realize in
the laboratory we terror is what we want
to do with them quantum simulators
design them and tell they may be
characterized them and formulate the
methods of validation but at the very
end we have to convince the
experimentalist that they should do it
so how does it work superconductors are
ideal conductors that conduct electric
currents without resistance this is
relatively simple so obviously they are
useful because they conduct strong
currents without losses they would solve
the have them at room temperature we
would solve the energetic problems of
mankind they also have very interesting
property that they can generate strong
magnetic fields outside of them but due
to the so called mice networks and felt
the effect
do not let magnetic fields inside so if
you cool the super the super conductor
below that we below the critical
temperature it pushes out the magnetic
fields this can be used to magnetic
levitation obviously if you make a
magnetic fields by some magnets around
it and it is used in fact to levitate
trains nowadays and unfortunately as you
know the superconductors exist only at
very low temperatures normally close to
absolute zero but high temperature
temperature
superconductors at the beginning where
the temperature is close to liquid
boiling of liquid nitrogen now they are
at around minus hundred degrees but
still it's not a room temperature even
in California so we some of their
additions working in physics believe
that there exists a simple model that
captures the phenomenon of high TC
superconductor it's the Hobart model
mentioned many times here unfortunately
even this simple model is far too hard
to simulate with with existing classical
computers so why not try mimic it with
atoms so the simple Hobart model is you
can think about it it's it's actually a
layer of this kind of boxes for eggs the
electrons are like eggs in this box and
they jump from one place to another and
there are two of them in one place they
interact one with another so jumping or
how pink is really tunneling between
through the barrier in this periodic
potential because electrons are not only
particles but in quantum mechanics they
are also wave packets so they can really
penetrate the by various and the
interaction is on site they repulse each
other it is a Coulomb propulsion but it
is screened in the solid state so it's
really short range only affected there
trivial in a sense and in fact the
formula that describes this is so long
so the complexity of this formula is
close to zero still the model is very
complex with atoms and we create this
periodic potential for the atoms by
putting lasers into this kind of in this
case three standing waves and this
standing waves of electric field of the
laser form a periodic potential for
atoms so in this figure you see a
three-dimensional actually lattice for
the atoms the balls are not atoms but
are the places in which atoms can see
then we load it with cold atoms with
bose-einstein condensate normally so
that we have one two five atoms per site
of this lattice and and that's it and
then we're and this atoms will hop if
the potential is not too deep and also
will interact one with another so it's a
perfect realization of the
but mother usually we can do it for the
sizes of the order of I don't know 30 by
30 by 30 so this order of magnitude of
size in 2d we can do it may be hundred
by hundred so let me tell you another
version of this idealogy of quantum
simulators which is essentially the same
but now there exist many interesting
classical optimization problems but such
as for instance spin glasses trailing
sides of salesmen and whatever and again
they have many important applications of
UC because many of them are C and P
complete and therefore if you but they
are very often very difficult to be
disguised understood with standard
computers so why not use another simpler
and better control of a quantum system
to solve or to get information about the
solution of this problems okay this is
really the ideology on which the wave
computers wave and such system we will
dance work also quantum simulator that
would be a quantum computer special
purpose but nowadays they are often
called quantum annealer because they use
quantum annealing as a method of solving
these problems or maybe even more
exactly they use something like
adiabatic computing going from one easy
state to the solution of the problem
adiabatically again famous Californian
okay what about the digital in principle
this is the logic that I presented of
course allows two to be either analog or
digital digital case you have error
Corrections and all the things that you
have associated with gates and things
like that in the case of analog there is
no error correction so there are more
questions concerning validation and so
on what shall we simulate this has been
already said by against statics at zero
temperatures of ground state and its
properties
statics are equilibrium dynamics at non
zero temperature I mean these two things
are very important because they will
tell you when the where and at which
parameters we have quantum phase
transitions two interesting states like
super conductivity but
similarly as in Martine stock we don't
really care so much about the value of
the ground state energy what is really
very important thing for us is there to
find the parameters the knobs which we
can turn in order to increase for
instance critical temperature for
superconductivity this is the very
important thing so it's like in
chemistry that differences between
energies which are important for us more
than absolute values in these
simulations we can similarly we would
like to simulate of course dynamics out
of equilibrium which also was mentioned
by N's and dissipative dynamics
platforms slowly again so that you
remember more the most developed
platform sister ultracold atoms in traps
superconductor means transfer so the
best thing is to do the in solid side
you would do the measurements of the of
the currents okay in atoms it is not so
easy but also you can do it nowadays
there are methods to do it ok but there
is other things there are correlations
and things like that which characterize
this in a sense you can think about the
superconductor is a condensation of kind
of pairs which is not completely true
because in strongly correlated regime it
doesn't apply this system but then it's
like a bose-einstein condensate between
the space so there is a phase coherence
between them ok and this can be measured
even in this opening the trap and this
time of flight sorry the first things
which was first so to say what's
ultracold atoms in traps not even in
lattices or on chips all right they
realize quantum field theory with Phi to
the four interactions or even more model
if you have longer interactions between
the atoms so for instance dipolar forces
or something like that so here I show
you a picture from the from the papers
of
and the group of crisps of Solomon in
Paris and the group of Martine still
lining at MIT
presenting the face diagram of the Fermi
ultra called Fermi gas to component
Fermi gas so you can think spin 1/2
fermions and this is a phase diagram the
pressure is a function this is at zero
temperature as a function of so called
Fermi momentum times scattering clients
which measures the stress of interaction
of the of the fermions and here chemical
potential in units of temperature so
this is in the regime of parameters in
which there is a cell phenomenon called
bcs bc crossover on one hand side when
the interactions are weakly attractive
the the electrons attract the electrons
these guys are atoms which mimic
electrons they attract each other and
they form the Cooper pairs but these
Cooper pairs are huge in space but they
are localizing momentum space okay the
on the other side here the effective
interaction scattering lines is positive
so they repulse each other but that
exists molecular states which have very
very small negative energy and they form
these molecules which are now localized
in space and this molecules condensed
into kabbalah possession condensate in
the middle interactions are infinite and
it is very very difficult to describe
of course on these pictures you see some
comparison with the with the with the
Monte Carlo diffusion diffusion Monte
Carlo mostly simulations but really in
the in the regime of this very strong
interactions there is still a lot of
open questions for in balanced system
and so on in which the computers do not
give us the answer called atoms in
optical lattices so here we can do
harbors models in particular and also
spin models this is a photo from emanuel
bluff
seminal experiment in which for the
first time this microscope for atoms was
realized in which they can show that
they can see individual atoms
essentially they have access to
individual to seeing individual
so here this is how the superfluid state
look like this is a bother her birth
mother now so these are bosons which
form condensate this is a condensate
this is when this bosons form a
so-called not insulator that is exactly
one atom per side and this is also Mott
insulator in which you have more atoms
so in the middle of the trap there are
two atoms per side one atom per side and
then nothing to atoms they cannot detect
because detection method is such that
they can only distinction between even
and not doesn't matter there is a book
about this which we wrote I think
published in 2012 but in last year there
was a paperback edition so you can get
it maybe below $50 knowledge and it's
corrected on top of the next platform
trapped ion source also mentioned but by
n so the ions are have two internal
states which serve as a qubit round and
excited it is easy to monitor whether
the atom whether they ion is in the
ground state because you can look at the
fluorescence to the side level and this
is a I would say hundred percent nearly
efficiency of checking the atoms these
ions interact with phonons and through
the phonons you can realize gates that
the most known is of course Sirach solar
gate and well and this is a very nice
system for a quantum simulations
although and this is example of quantum
simulations of the Hamiltonian which is
this kind of easing in transverse field
for I think six four four spins and this
is the more exotic Hamiltonian with six
spin interaction was done in the group
of Reiner blood so here time is of
course you apply this gates many many
times but you can do it with very good
fidelity you can also do it in analog
manner okay next one is circuit QED here
what is happening is that you have small
microwave cavities in which there can be
my clock
with photons and that is superconducting
qubit inside and this realizes the
famous model of quantum electrodynamics
so-called James Cummings model
interaction of two-level atom with with
a single amount of radiation and this
cavities can interact one with another
because the photons can tunnel from one
place to another that's why this kind of
simulations are called curvy simulation
of cavity QED the superconducting qubits
or arise of those which can simulate for
instance these things in glasses and you
know what it is and finally photonic
platforms which were also mentioned
today and usually you have a sit in
photonic platforms you usually have
photons on the input they go to some set
of wave guides they can tunnel from one
waveguide to another and then you sample
at the end this the boosting to this
kind of technical platform was actually
caused by the paper by Scott in which he
showed that at some situation you can
from this measurement get information
about the np-hard problem which is the
calculation of permanent of the
corresponding I would say transmission
matrix for this so I showed you two
interesting systems that was reported
this year one is for ultra cold gases in
the trap in this case is in fact mixture
of two kinds of bosons which attract
each other so normally if there would be
standard mean field theory applied to
describe the system they would collapse
okay because they attract each other
however there are quantum effects beyond
mean field which is essentially the zero
point fluctuations of energy which
depend on the density of these guys and
this the zero point fluctuations
stabilize the system so that they can
form what people call quant
droplets because this is these are the
things that are similar to helium
droplets they have higher density than
BC and they're very different so I show
you the the experiment has been done
actually in need for in my Institute and
by my colleague Leticia farewell and
here maybe look at this picture this is
when the interaction you can control the
interaction between this was on see if
this interaction is repulsive then if
you have the cloud of these bosons in
the trap and you open the trap well the
if spread yeah because nothing keep them
in the place they diffuse if the
interaction is too attractive
then this call up so call you open the
trap but that they don't go away but
they call ups into something very small
and then in the intermediate situation
when the interaction are not so negative
not so attractive if you open the trap
the thing stays there and forms this
droplet of high density again there are
some simulations Montecarlo for this
system but it's absolutely not yet clear
whether these systems are superfluid
what are the properties and so on and
their mouse probably this will not be
easy to to simulate in the normal
computers with precision because it is
really strongly correlated another
example is the famous cold atom Fermi
Hobart model this is from Marcus Reiner
group from last year
this fixed so this is really studying
against ITC superconductive ET so this
is the figure that I think yen's shown
so you can see this is what we expect
the phase diagram of the system is you
have antiferromagnet here when you
assume here that they and when the
number of atoms or electrons per site is
exactly one you are here in the in the
anti ferromagnetic phase if you start
taking this atoms away and you have less
atoms then and then sites then you enter
strange phases so called soy de Graaff a
source french metal phase Fermi liquid
this is relatively normal phase but
still
and the do a superconductor this is what
we believe you know I never in this
paper that was reported lat
last year was able to go with his system
on this line from the Mott insulator to
the anti ferromagnetic order and then
into the face of the strange metal so
this is how the pictures with this
single atom microscope youth look like
this is when he is at at this point and
then you see that you start seeing this
kind of check about here which means
that he takes out one spin component and
what is left should my should look like
a checkerboard pattern expressing the
ferromagnetic order now there are much
more advanced experiments in which he
has reached even lower temperatures and
enterpise but I have no time to talk
about it let me talk a little about this
errors validation and how I'm doing on
time okay so first thing he would like
to maybe measure or optimize his energy
or cost functions with these things of
course this can be also very hard
problem to compute but I'm saying in a
sense you can maybe go to smaller
systems and use variational upper bounds
using tensor networks and things like
that you have some control on the arrow
here you can use finite size scaling to
see how it how it goes there is also an
interesting idea that there are saying
semi definite programming methods for
the lower bounds of the energy I mean
here this was pioneered by Tanya seen in
this paper Sun which they really based
it on the characterization of the
correlations in quantum systems and
there is in particular also the
pioneering work which was into 2008 but
this is more is longer and has more
information and there is also a nice
paper by Tillman bomgaarts and Martine
clinic where they explicitly construct
methods to car to calculate lower bouts
for energy validation what does it mean
validation well validation means go to
parameters regime
simulations are efficient so how what
can it be suppose that you want to do
frustrated system alright so in the
frustrated system very often Montecarlo
doesn't work because there is a sign
problem so you go to low frustration and
maybe there Montecarlo works or works
better you check it there and then you
go to the regime of parameters in which
in which you don't know is that i
incognita but this is the same with the
normal classical computers of course you
have more methods of checking conv
convergence and so on but here also you
can check that how repeat when you
repeat the experiment you should get the
same results and things like that
another possibility is always go to
small system where you can always do
simulation classically and use finite
size scaling so this is a seminal paper
from the emmanuel block group where they
take again this Bossa hubbard model and
they compare it with the best of the bed
creme de la creme of Monte Carlo
simulations and Monte Carlo simulators
men simulator men ok la de poulet and
Nikolay prop Prokofiev Buddhist cistern
of and Matthias Troyer so here is the
ideal phase diagram of this water Harbor
was a Hubbard model and here are
comparison between between the numerical
Monte Carlo simulation and the
experiment which are perfect ok they
even did it for time-of-flight pictures
so they opened the trap they let the
thing go if this is super fluid they see
this kind of nice
interference Bragg Peaks and in the mud
face they see this kind of fuzzy things
and this is the simulation so everything
is fine here because Monte Carlo is
working for this kind of system there is
no problem but of course if you would go
to bigger system then in order to make
comparison you would have to buy a new
computer for a couple of million dollars
so in this sense it is a goat simulator
the experimental system I mean and
finally not finally robustness what we
meant by this robustness is that one of
the things that you can do
in this experiment sis you really can
add perturbations in a controlled way
so disorder or no it's time-dependent
and you can check how sensitive you are
and this gives you an information how
well you have to determine your
constants in the Hamiltonian to do to
get what you want ready to get okay so
like in the chemistry they told us one
over thousand and grad so here you can
also check it to some extent and with
wrote a paper about it to review in a
couple of years in reports on progress
in physics and the example that I show
here is a one-dimensional system
everything can be of course calculated
here but we look at the correlation
Lance which is in these colors at the
critical point of the transverse field
teasing model and we check how does it
decreases with growing disorder and also
how the critical temperature this is
this line actually increases with the
growing disorder okay and in the sense
this is the way of calculating the
sensitivity all right finally
certification this is more modern term
you can certify entanglement or
certified even nonlocality in these
systems and this is more or less our
answering the following question very
often we want we expect that the ground
state of the system or even we want to
prepare the ground at the ground state
of the system such that it is entangled
and how can we be sure about it in this
kind of an earless things we can ask is
this device really quantum computer or
simulator or not are the results correct
and things like that so the new methods
for this kind of certification are being
proposed in the recent years and I will
show you few this is popular first of
all we can measure something this is the
first measurement of entanglement
entropy again by the Markos Griner group
very method which was proposed by DT
reacts many years ago he has a system
divides into two and he measures the
swap operator on behalf of the system so
he makes two copies and makes a swap
operator on the copy is very complicated
experiment
but hopefully and of course what he
measures in this way is that when I
entropy this of the other side too but
sooner in last year I think there was no
in this year actually pub this was this
beautiful paper by sea rock and solar in
which they show that you can measure
this Rene ten trapeze if you apply
random unit arrest will reduce density
matrix you measure this kind of
projection on state in a given basis and
you have a new average this probability
distribution if you calculate this
average over the random unit Aires then
for instance for P squared you could
directly the Rene entropy now how do you
realize random unit Alice this is what
the paper is about you do it with some
random conscious the method is shown and
it is validated and that it works quite
well
and this matter Pesci was used this a
very similar method were used by Marcos
Greiner to study entanglement in the
many body localization problem but I
have no time to talk about it the one
that I want two more papers that I want
to mention is one is efficient device
independent entanglement detection by
multiple tied systems which is by
Tonia's in group what they have is they
build hierarchy of the sets that limit
the local the the set of local
correlations so the ones that do not
break bellini qualities from outside we
know that the quantum sticks out
somewhere here so it's a moment these
sets which are relatively easy to
characterize will if we get a kind of
Bell inequality touching this set we
will also have a witness of entanglement
this is more or less the idea the other
thing that we can also do and this we
did already for in 2014 we proposed how
to detect nonlocality in many body
systems so we do it by with Bell
inequalities which involves only two
body correlators that's why it is
possible to characterize this
- but this kind of baling it but it is
actually we have character is all of
them for the case when they are
symmetric with respect to permutations
of the particles and this is a very nice
method because it also allow for for the
device independent witnessing of many
body entangle T even so here in the
figure I show you the more you violate
this Bell inequality the the amount the
deeper you are in this region because
this is quantum forbidden region if you
are below of one of these blue lines
then you can be sure that your system is
more than K producible k produces
abilities that you can produce a state
with the clusters of K particles and
things like that so you have test of
many-body entanglement here and the last
figure that I wanted to show this is
another way of presenting the same
diagram this is how deeply you violate
this inequality this is some parameter
of the system that they were measuring
and this is experimental result actually
from the basal group which they obtained
as that that they can be sure that they
measured the entanglement with 30 to
produce ability so at least 32 guys are
genetically entangled in this system and
with this I finish my conclusion is
usually enjoy physics and beyond what
here is different
[Applause]
[Music]
okay I would rather say that one thing
is the quantum simulation we want to
prepare interesting states in particular
the states which are strongly correlated
and in this States you would expect that
you would have a lot of eight argument
so you want to certify it and how do you
certify entanglement in many body
systems I mean these are the papers
which try to propose the experimentally
feasible methods of measuring
entanglement and and not even
nonlocality in this many body systems
thank you I think that this is what I
can tell you the relation is that this
is a certification tool that what you do
is correct it's not related to
simulation itself but when you simulate
you want to do now that at the end you
have created something interesting so
you measure many buddy integral meant
for instance okay this is the only thing
it's a diagnostic tool you know I just
mean you show a picture the d-wave
machine but last year d-wave claimed
that they could map an 8 by 8 by 8 group
of spins into their machine they buried
the magnetic field
and they measured critical exponents and
you know so they turned it into a
machine physical simulation and I wonder
how you know you you were listing all
these different people who did groups
that didn't include that experiment are
you I mean still as I know as I I'm not
aware of quantum simulation time
dependent of the
I always thought that they are doing
some optimization problems which are
classical I never had the day they use
the cubic lattice into the machine
they're in the magnetic field and
measured critical exponents and so there
was a there was a you know device with
512 qubits I can't judge it because I
don't even know I saw him I saw I I saw
him in November I know Evan in in
February but they mercy I mean then in
February they mostly talked about what
they did before which was the easing
classical using and about the machine
learning relation and the fact that they
can sometimes do better way of
optimizing the backpropagation saying
that these are the things but I never
heard about this but
but exponent for the quantum phase
transition I think it's hard to believe
if I think what they could have done
they could have done three dimensional
easing in now but even that it will be
very difficult probably they could do
treatments easing in magnetic field
uniform and they can look for the
transition there and then to calculate
the exponents dates I can imagine but
for the quantum I'm skeptical
as far as I understand
when the temperature was just not low
enough to relieve quantum critical
region and the second problem is that
the system is fundamentally strongly
coupled to the environment and once you
are in this kind of quantum critical
regime this coupling to environment
certainly plays a role so and that's why
I think it's not like I'm not sure like
this I will check I will check I will
check tonight and tomorrow if anybody
wants to discuss er I'm ready to do that
yes yes okay so I think what we've done
for the day was the boss
[Applause]